these days everybody's got a racket  bootleggers gin joints brothels I don't  care what you're running there's just  one rule in our town everybody pays  what is this place oh my god no  magnificent is welcome to Rosie's thorns  may I come in  be my guest  and now for all you good god-fearing  people out there  I have the true queen of the night  [Applause]  sure this wasn't a hunting accident no I  told you it was some kind of animal I've  seen this before  back in the war there was this medic he  was feeding on the dead  these demons will suck this town dry do  you know how to kill a vampire  done nice mistake  I prepared you'll need me  you  you